so I'm a I'm a devotee and complete
fanatic for the infinite game and having
an infinite mindset
and very quickly
um just a quick definition so you know
what I'm talking about
um
Dr James Carson the mid-1980s defined
these two types of games finite games
and infinite games
um uh a finite game is known players
fixed rules and agreed upon objective
football baseball there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if
there's a winner necessarily they have
to be losers then you have infinite
games infinite games are defined as
known and unknown players which means
new players can join anytime and you
don't necessarily know who all the other
players are you definitely don't know
every Brewery in the world you know
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
um turns out business is an infinite
game you know when Circuit City went
bankrupt Best Buy didn't win anything
um uh they had to keep playing
companies come and go and yet the game
continues with you or without you and
there's no such thing as winning nobody
wins business it doesn't exist
um but if you listen to the language of
too many leaders it becomes abundantly
clear they don't always know the game
they're playing in they talk about being
number one or being the best or beating
their competition
based on what you know and I love it
when Executives come to me and say you
know we are number one and I always say
for now
you know
um and so and so um the idea of building
a company that can survive every single
employee in this room after you've long
gone and that that company remains true
to its purpose
um is a very very powerful thing a great
example is right outside the front door
you know the Walt Disney Company
um you know the purpose that Disney
founded and they've they've gone through
you know trials and tribulations for
sure
um ins and outs but for the most part
you know when they are at their natural
best they are they hearken back to their
founding purpose and I love that I love
that uh you know you ask me is it
essential
I mean depends on what kind of company
you want to run
um if you want a company that that can
continue to innovate and set set the
course for what business should look
like Define what Innovation looks like
in your industry long before you're all
you know long after you're all gone then
build that company but if you want to
build a company that just
um sucks the life out of people who work
there and does damage the you know to
the industry all the name of it does
damage to the the communities in which
we work all in the name of short-term
gains you can build that company too and
it'll come at a much steeper cost in
terms of Love loyalty you know
Etc et cetera so
yeah